dibujemos la estructura de puntos de
lewis para el tri fluoruro de boro
usando la teoría de sfr por sus siglas
en inglés también conocida como trpv1
erp esp es la teoría de repulsión de
pares de electrones de valencia y dice
que como los electrones de valencia se
repelen provocan que la molécula adopte
una cierta geometría entonces primero
dibujemos la estructura de puntos para
el tri fluoruro de boro el boro se
encuentra en el grupo 3 de la tabla
periódica tiene 3 electrones de valencia
y como el flúor se encuentra en el grupo
7 tiene 7 electrones de valencia pero
como tenemos tres átomos de flúor 7 por
3 es igual a 21 y 21 más 3 nos da 24
electrones de valencia en total que
colocaremos
nuestra estructura ahora como el boro es
menos electro negativo que el flúor lo
ponemos en el centro rodeado de los tres
átomos de flúor
hasta ahora hemos colocado 6 electrones
de valencia
aquí tenemos 2 4 y 6 entonces 24 menos 6
nos falta colocar 18 electrones de
valencia y los podemos poner en nuestros
átomos terminales que en este caso son
los átomos de flúor como cada flor ya
tiene 2 electrones a su alrededor
podemos agregar 6 electrones más para
completar su octeto así que ponemos 6
electrones de valencia en cada uno de
los tres átomos de flúor 6 por 3 es
igual a 18 así que ya colocamos todos
los electrones de valencia ahora
observen que el boro no cumple con la
regla del octeto sin embargo no hay
problema podemos explicarlo con la carga
formal
recuerden que cada enlace covalente
consiste en
los electrones y para asignar la carga
formal
necesitamos el número de electrones de
valencia del átomo libre que en el caso
del boro es 3 y a este número le
restamos el número de electrones que
rodean al átomo en la molécula observen
que en estos enlaces uno de los
electrones está más cerca del flúor y el
otro está más cerca del borde así que el
boro está rodeado por tres electrones de
valencia entonces 3 menos 3 es igual a 0
recuerden nuestro objetivo al dibujar
estructuras de puntos de louis es
minimizar la carga formal y esta es una
estructura aceptable aún cuando el boro
no cumple con la regla del octeto aunque
podría estar rodeado por 8 electrones si
algunos de estos pares de electrones
libres del flúor se compartieran con el
boro lo que le daría al boro una
carga formal y contribuiría a la
estructura general de la molécula en
nuestro caso sólo nos interesa tener una
estructura aceptable como esta la red
dibujaré un poco diferente
pongamos todos los pares de electrones
libres
entonces el segundo paso es contar el
número de nubes electrónicas que rodean
al átomo central recuerden que las nubes
electrónicas o nubes de electrones son
regiones de densidad electrónica que
pueden ser tanto enlaces como pares de
electrones libres entonces aquí tenemos
una nube electrónica aquí tenemos otra y
por acá tenemos otra así que tenemos
tres nubes electrónicas alrededor del
átomo central que se repelen entre sí y
eso nos permite predecir la geometría
quieren estar lo más lejos posible y en
este caso eso ocurre cuando todas las
nubes electrónicas se encuentran en el
mismo plano imaginen que esta es una
hoja de papel nuestro plan y tenemos al
boro en el centro rodeado de sus tres
nubes de electrones
que se encuentran lo más lejos posible
entre ellas a esta geometría se le
conoce como trigon al plan
esta es la geometría tribunal plana de
las nubes electrónicas que rodean al
átomo central y como no tenemos ningún
parte electrones libres en el átomo
central la geometría de la molécula
también es tribunal plan ahora respecto
al ángulo de enlace en esta geometría
vamos a pensar en un círculo como los
electrones se repelen de la misma forma
podemos dividir nuestro círculo en tres
ángulos equivalentes es decir 360 entre
3 es igual a 120 así que todos los
ángulos entre enlaces en esta molécula
son de 120 grados entonces tenemos una
molécula con geometría trigo na y un
ángulo de enlace de 120 grados
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora tenemos
dióxido de azufre contemos los
electrones de valencia el azufre se
encuentra en el grupo 6 así que tiene 6
electrones de valencia y el oxígeno
también se encuentra en el grupo 6 pero
como tenemos 26 por 2 es igual a 12 más
tenemos 18 electrones de valencia en
total entonces como el azufre es menos
electro negativo que el oxígeno lo
ponemos al centro rodeado de 2 oxígenos
y ya colocamos 4 electrones de valencia
aquí tenemos 2 y 2 entonces 18 menos 4
nos faltan 14 electrones por colocar y
podemos empezar en los átomos terminales
los oxígenos que para completar su
octeto solo necesitan
los electrones más así que le agregamos
6 electrones a cada oxígeno 6 por 2
hemos colocado 12 electrones de valencia
entonces 14 menos 12 aún nos faltan 2
electrones de valencia y recordemos que
si aún nos quedan electrones los podemos
poner en el átomo central así que
tenemos un par de electrones libres en
el azufre observen que el azufre no ha
completado su octeto y al calcular su
carga formal encontrarán que aún no se
ha minimizado así que necesitamos
compartir algunos electrones podemos
tomar algún par de electrones libres por
ejemplo este par de electrones y
moverlos hacia acá para formar un doble
enlace entre el azufre y el oxígeno
entonces nos queda un doble enlace entre
el azul
y uno de los oxígenos que termina con
dos pares de electrones libres mientras
que el oxígeno de la izquierda permanece
igual con sus tres pares de electrones
libres y no olvidemos el par de
electrones libres en el azufre si
asignamos cargas formales
vamos a ver sabemos que cada enlace
tiene dos electrones y vamos primero con
el oxígeno de la izquierda el oxígeno
libre tiene seis electrones de valencia
y en nuestra estructura uno de los
electrones en azul está más cerca del
oxígeno así que el oxígeno está rodeado
de siete electrones entonces 6 menos 7
tenemos una carga formal de menos 1
ahora vamos con el azufre observen que
el azufre está rodeado por 5 electrones
de valencia como en el azufre hay 66 -5
tenemos una carga formal más 1 tenemos
una carga formal de más 1 en el azufre y
de menos 1 en este oxígeno así que aún
cuando no tenemos una carga formal igual
a 0 las cargas se neutraliza otra forma
podría ser que en lugar de tomar un par
de electrones libres de este oxígeno
tomemos un par de este otro eso nos
daría otra estructura de resonancia pero
vamos a quedarnos con esta estructura
déjenme redibujar la vamos a enfocarnos
en la geometría ya tenemos nuestra
estructura de puntos de louis regresemos
a nuestros pasos
ahora necesitamos contar el número de
nubes electrónicas que rodean al átomo
central
hay que identificar las regiones en
donde hay densidad electrónica ya sea
enlaces o pares de electrones libres
entonces alrededor de nuestro átomo
central el azufre aquí tenemos una nube
electrónica del lado derecho tenemos un
doble enlace pero lo podemos considerar
como una nube electrónica es una región
de densidad electrónica y finalmente
tenemos este par de electrones libres
que también es una nube electrónica así
que tenemos tres nubes electrónicas y
como vimos en el ejemplo anterior tres
nubes electrónicas adoptan una geometría
trigo na trataré de dibujar
se ve algo así y pondré este orbital
entonces la geometría de las nubes
electrónicas es trigon al plan y
esperaríamos que los ángulos de enlace
sean de aproximadamente 120 grados pero
regresemos a nuestros pasos para
predecir la geometría de la molécula ya
hicimos el paso 3
predecimos la geometría de las nubes
electrónicas alrededor del átomo central
y ahora vamos con el paso 4
tenemos que ignorar cualquier par de
electrones libres alrededor del átomo
central para predecir la geometría de la
molécula entonces debemos ignorar el par
de electrones libres en el azufre este
par de electrones para predecir la
geometría de la molécula así que aún
cuando la geometría de las nubes
electrónicas es tribunal plana la
geometría de la molécula es diferente
de una forma como ésta corresponde a la
geometría angular
esta es una geometría angular estos
fueron dos ejemplos de moléculas con
tres nubes electrónicas y recuerden que
hay que ignorar los pares de electrones
libres alrededor del átomo central para
predecir la geometría final de la
molécula